baby you look like a hundred and
forty-six million domestic Thank You
Belle thank you everybody over at Sony
thanks you as well
anyway now to the business at hand the
cinematographers are the technical
heroes of the filmmaking world both
Leigh creating the looks that transport
us into the stories that transform us
visionaries
magicians creative electricians they
wire the images that make all the
difference no Amy but the
cinematographer that wrote those words
certainly was don't you think all right
you're the brains of the operation -
baby tell him tell him who's up for best
shooter here are the nominees for
achievement in cinematography the grand
master Phillipe loose or gravity
Emmanuel Lubezki inside Llewyn Davis
Bruno Dallben Elle Nebraska Baden Papa
Michael prisoners Roger Deakins oh we
forgot one Harold Ramis for Caddyshack
Ghostbusters and groundhog
[Music]
please forgive me gentlemen the 2013
Oscar for the Best Cinematography and a
major motion picture who's going to go
home with gravity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to thank the Academy for this
amazing award I would like to share a
base with the cast and crew I know
everybody says that but I truly I want
to share with the cast and crew
especially with my friend and my teacher
mr. Alfonso Cuaron heavenly to your
passion and your creativity and your
drive incredible and with Tim Weber and
the team of Framestore nerds that make
this trip possible I want to share it as
well with David Heyman and Warner
Brothers for making the movie and with
Sandy Bullock from Drita you're
absolutely amazing - my wife Lauren Sita
Alejandra and Danny my daughters
my parents my family my friends my
teachers not all of them but some of
them and thank you so much good night
[Applause]